hey guys we've got some brand new merch
to tell you about the tie-dye be good to
yourself teas are now available
you can get those in aqua creamsicle and
indigo get that in more at
theovanstore.com
and I have some new tour dates to
announce I will be in Lincoln California
on September 15th at the venue at
Thunder Valley
and Las Vegas Nevada
on October 27th and 28th at Resorts
World Las Vegas tickets for these shows
are available starting Wednesday July
26th with code Rat King
we've also got some new shows in Toronto
Ontario on August 31st
we've added that new show and Milwaukee
Wisconsin on September 8th at the Miller
High Life theater
today's guest is uh is a native of Tampa
Florida
he's one of the most known
human beings in the entire world he's
one of the most recognizable figures
um he headlined eight wrestlemanias and
he headlined my childhood if I'm really
honest with you uh I'm grateful to get
to spend time with him today he's a
Entertainer an athlete a movie star uh
today's guest is Mr Hulk Hogan
[Music]
[Applause]
you just eat one of your own teeth
if you did that's the toughest thing
I've ever seen anybody do
no but I did buy the piece of bacon when
these veneers fell off I almost ate it
yeah
I could see you eat my I could just see
you just having one you know I was flare
did you behave at all dude the guy I'm
gonna just go out on a limb and say the
guy's got some issues
you think yeah
I mean he just he'd drink his own blood
if it you told him in a gin in it I
think yeah you know are we filming huh
are we filming we don't have to we will
never even filming yeah I don't know if
we're filming yet are we recording yeah
okay yeah because
30 years I never saw him take a drink of
water yeah brother breakfast
hard liquor vitamins hard liquor yeah
lunch a couple beers hard to look at
night wine I love him to death oh yeah
but I never saw him drink drink any
water until recently and I think he's
back off the water back on the roll
again yeah he said he's back here he
said he did 30 days sober and then
walked across the street to a bar and
turned in his chip yeah
the funny part is he can he just can
he's that's who he is that's the man the
funny part is when he was had that
really serious health issue yeah
um I got a call from Wendy and it didn't
look good so I flew up we got a plane
right away flew up to Atlanta
and uh
I walked in the doctor pulled me sorry I
was saying your buddy here
has destroyed his body the inside of
some of his intestines and stuff were
dying and stuff because he's got a five
percent chance
of making it through the surgery
so he goes in
we wait I was Jimmy Hart was with me who
waited we waited whether he comes out
you're still alive
um his girl's crying his daughter
Ashley's crying I'm sitting there
holding his hand holding Zan
five percent chance to make it he opens
his eyes he looks up after he goes Hogan
get me a six-pack
what first thing he said to me get me a
six-pack when he woke up
yeah I'm not shocked man oh no I was
just tripping man just kind of blew my
mind you know yeah he's a good guy bro
he's one he's the best there ever was
he's uh well he would he and he says
that about you you know no he's the best
there ever was is he the better wrestler
is he the better and is he the Best
Entertainer is he the best wrestler he
was more consistent because I quit and I
really didn't care about the business I
came from playing in a rock and roll
band yeah and that whole attitude
but once he got in it he was you know he
was real consistent and he held it down
like when I was doing the New York
Madison Square Garden thing he held the
southern belt thing down which was
actually a little harder because he was
going an hour every night sometimes
they'd do like what they call it
Broadways where nobody wins you do like
two-hour Broadways with Harley Race just
just those two in the ring yeah because
they didn't want to switch the belt so
they didn't want to make either
wrestlers okay you're going out Broadway
tonight wow so somebody told me to go
now Broadway just beat me I'm out of
here I'm going to get room service and a
beer you know yeah you know I say he was
the best serverless simply because he
was so consistent now I was talking
about who drew the most money
or internationally who saturated all the
international markets over the years you
know I had more time and I had more seat
time like a good race car driver I had
more seat time in all these foreign
markets and Rick spent the majority of
his career down south and he didn't have
that yeah that swing arm to plug in that
Mozambique zambali Malaysia all these
places where people will know who Hulk
Hogan is but they might not know who Tom
Brady is right
but you know he uh he was the man I love
working with him yeah
yeah he he um he's a scrappy he just
will not be denied really you know
there's something about him and there
was something about that whole NWA
um I don't know if it was AWA or NWA at
that time when he was really the king of
it you know but it came on I think on
Sunday night like it was almost like I
had friends that watched wrestling right
they knew you but I knew if they really
watched wrestling if they knew about
um if they knew about NWA you know
that's when you could tell if they were
the next level of you know it
was a lot of guys that just couldn't
even read and they'd be in the stands
yelling just signs misspelled yeah you
had me dialed in to be like that whole
Crockett Southern belt promotion you had
to be a wrestling fan oh yeah rabies I
feel like I was more accessible to the
housewives and the kids that didn't know
what wrestling was yeah you know so it
was a whole different thing but then
Rick came our way yeah and I'd been
begging him to come up there for years
he wouldn't leave
and then uh once he came up then we
started rocking you know was it scary
whenever he got over to WWE did you feel
a little bit of like holy how's
this gonna go because that's
a lot of ego you know it's all there's
at that point there's a lot of ego there
can only be so many men on the top of
the you know on the mountain tops
well it's kind of like you know it's
hard to explain but I play the dumb Fox
a lot you know and for me I'm always
looking who's got the big dollar sign on
their chest yeah and I don't mean to be
an egomaniac but I mean I could actually
wrestle anybody at that time and sell
out I mean we sold out everywhere
constantly for years yeah it didn't
matter if I wrestled Flair or Kamala or
Paul horned off Mr Wonderful or it
didn't matter you could wrestle
Hunter Biden dude I'd come yeah
but yeah it was uh
it was it wasn't that with me it was
I wanted him to get over so I would have
somebody to work with and chase you know
so that was me it was about for me it
was like the old school thing the money
and the miles you know so you know I
wasn't really
um that into being on the road or
getting beat on every night yeah but
there was so much paper involved bro I
was in yeah
yeah do you think that you felt more
like an athlete did you feel I mean
because you came from a music background
did you feel more like an athlete did
you feel more like a like this is just
did you almost make wrestling your music
in a way does that make any sense
because you're hitting you're hitting it
on all these cylinders there I really
wasn't an elite athlete that was great
on the football field or you know a
great wrestler you know amateur wrestler
or y'all had a baseball background but I
didn't you know played Major League
Baseball I had a couple of things that
happened to me that stopped all that
stuff but I looked at myself more as
just she said it's like an art form
extension of my music and when I once I
figured out what the business was about
because you can Google Hulk Hogan in
Japan you can see me get down and
wrestle like Bret Hart and all the guys
because that's how I started you know
back in the day here I think I'm here on
Matsu broke my leg the first day ran me
off put me in the Doge over two years
long wrestling hook submissions
you know so you learned it all well I
went through the motions because back
then if you got your ass beating the bar
brother you were out of the wrestling
business yeah you know back in the 70s
it was back in the late 70s a little bit
different than the performance center
now with the WWE yeah you know oh I can
I can only imagine you had to live the
lifestyle then yeah and you had to
protect the business and if you wanted a
job there's a 300 pound guy over there
with cauliflowers you had to take the
food out of his wife and kids mouth to
get in the business yeah it wasn't like
you know there's 40 wrestlers here that
have been training you know at the
performance center we can pick one when
one gets hurt and replace replace him it
wasn't that way right it was way
different back then but yeah it was a it
was uh
something that once I figured the
business out you know I kind of like
watched a bunch of guys growing up like
I watched Dusty Rhodes look because I
was from here you know and then I also
watched Superstar Billy Graham a lot and
I kind of like stole a little bit from
both of them
and then I was digging and rustling and
digging and wrestling around here and
then I quit and I went to you know
Northern Florida through P Cola and
Mobile Alabama Birmingham Alabama
wrestled and Russell then I quit
that I went up to Memphis for a while
and I quit when you were quitting what
was it making you quit kind of was it
just the money bro I was wrestling like
12 13 times a week there give me a check
for 125 oh yeah when you're beating the
out of somebody at a Best Western
yeah and I was gigging my head for five
bucks a night and then in between rock
and roll bands one of the lead singers
in my band got me in the laborers union
here because in between bands we'd go
put our go to the labor labor hall and
they pull your number you may get a job
for four days at the mall working with
the uh a pipefitter or three days at a
government shutdown working with
electricians and I got uh a call to go
be a longshoreman help a longshoremen I
get in the union down there in where in
Florida yeah on 22nd Street Causeway in
Florida okay so once I learned how to be
it was a weird place because I was
probably the first white guy ever in the
longshoreman Houston here in Tampa oh
wow mostly Latinos Latinos and blacks
yeah and so then I learned how to load
the ships and I became a stevedore but
in between wrestling I was like man 13
14 times this week twice on Wednesday
twice on Saturday three times on Sunday
I wrestled for 125 I'm going back to the
dock so I was making 400 bucks a day
yeah you know eating the gimmicks and
working 14 15 hours you know it just
didn't pay no so I quit quit I went back
and forth back and forth but um then I
figured the business out right then I
went back and one time I slammed
somebody I went
I wish to the crowd like that in the
reaction
got more response than the body slam
yeah wait a minute let me hit somebody
of throat and then yeah I'm looking
another action go you know more I said
okay now I got it it took me a while to
figure it out
and then when I get fired from the WWF
The First Time by event senior when I
went to make the Rocky movie I went and
spent three years in Minnesota and then
I figured it out all right the whole
Mania thing out the ripping the shirt
the hulking up but I wasn't an elite
athlete but I figured the business out
and I got real good
yeah
instead of getting somebody in the
corner kicking them 20 times like the
guys do I'd kick somebody once and leave
them lying yeah and I said don't get up
and I'd walk around and strut like a
peacock and do my thing and I figured
out how to create emotion and drama
and get people really pissed off at me
really happy with me so
I just kind of figured it out man but I
had enough of an athletic ability to
have balance and you know basically
replacement have a Cadence in the ring
which you know a lot of guys can figure
out
yeah man it's just it's really it's it's
uh it's kind of fascinating to see like
what because I I don't as a fan like
dude I remember
like you we would try to stay up for
Saturday Night Main Event man and we
were a kid and was like I remember
my brother and I holding each other's
eyes open because because we can come on
till 10 30 right and like we were
sitting there and we would wake
up in the morning we'd be like what did
you see like we missed it we were like
when you would come on it was like
man it didn't matter how poor we were it
didn't matter if my parents were too
busy it didn't matter if I wasn't a
tough kid it was like
yeah I fell in love with you it was like
I didn't care about the wrestling you
know like I did the wrestling was cool
but I cared about whoever that per like
whoever they made me whatever they made
me feel you know and when you it was
like it made me feel like man this is an
escape like and I fell more in love with
the yeah the person not the moves like
it didn't matter who's the most athletic
right you know Snuka was fun to watch
because he had you know this hair coming
off of it you know in these you know
domestic charges or whatever just
dangling off of them but he was like but
otherwise it was like yeah it was about
the person it wasn't about as much the
wrestling yeah I figured that out bro
and that whole
thing I slid into you know that from
Venice Beach California of course I'm
from here yeah my whole life
and that that whole being tanner than
everybody and having the blonde hair and
and just kind of like the training
prayers and vitamins that impeccable
baby face character you know it kind of
like was just perfect timing with
everything oh yeah so I kind of figured
out you know right away you know that
the character worked and I saw how I
kind of like came up with a little bit
better character than everybody else
around me and I just wrote it till it
dropped I picked it up and I wrote it
some more and I spanked it and wrote it
some more and even when Vince told me
you know he runs over and I think you're
done with it I said okay see you later
let's work for Ted Turner for 10 years
and taught everybody a lesson that was
NWO yeah and then I went in the red and
yellow for a couple years then we've
kind of felt a little Runway I needed to
do something evil you know and then that
got red hot so you had good instincts
then yeah you say that yeah you see a
good instance yeah yeah well I came into
New York in 77 as a bad guy because I
sold out Shea Stadium with Andre in 78
and then I went all around Japan I spent
20 years in Japan six months out of the
Year oh hey that's what I'm saying
Google some of my matches people know
about that as much no not really and
what was that lifestyle I mean you guys
get over there first of all you're twice
as big as anybody there you're as big as
some families don't weigh as much as you
there well first off I was single right
when I went over there I didn't get
married till 80
three end of 83 December so in 77 I went
over there
and the guy that broke my leg the first
day was a guy named him yeah right and
then they ran me off you know because I
had real arm blonde hair all the way
down to my ass coming out of the rock
and roll band thinking I could be a
wrestler duh
and then I went back a few months later
when I got home my dad beat my ass worse
than matsuda did damn he said don't you
ever let anybody hurt you again so you
know let's strike me right up so a few
months later when my leg was healed I
went back and I had that attitude you
know because I was when I was younger I
was real strong and and you know kind of
aggressive and um so I said I'm not
gonna let these guys hurt me you know so
I just didn't let him take my arm right
you know and so I went back and you know
then they couldn't run me off and they
did everything he could to get rid of me
finally they just said okay we need to
teach this guy he ain't going nowhere so
I spent a couple years in Japan learning
the submissions Hooks and all the UFC
stuff and to protect myself not much but
I weren't enough to protect myself
and uh you know then when I went to
Japan
I had this Mystique of hero matsuda
broke me in and so that carried a lot of
weight and then just like we had Elvis
here the Japanese at the time had a real
famous Japanese singer like Elvis had
his hair bleached out and here I come
the new I played music so the first
thing I did was I went in the studio and
I cut up cut an album with a the most
popular Japanese band called pink Cloud
so I went and cut an album with them and
so right away I got over so they love
you then the other thing was I brought
Freddy blasty with me I don't know if
you know who he's classy pretty blasty
right and he used to wrestle against him
Ricky dozen in Japan who was a mafia guy
because all all the wrestling in Japan
is run by the mafia TV a sign
everything's all Mafia at the time right
I hope they're not listening
but no that's cool it's cool yeah but
yeah so now I show up with blassie and
blassie had false teeth he had a set of
teeth he ate with then when he wrestled
he'd follow this other set of teeth down
oh that's what he would do yeah and he
would bite these guys in the head suck
the bottom of the head and spit the
blood in their face oh yeah and his
first tour over there three old ladies
died watching TV oh God so now I come
over with him
so I got matte suit under my belt I cut
this music so the Japanese think I'm
some you know Superstar because I just
played music back in the day and now I'm
with blasty so you were a king there as
soon as I walked in there you know I was
over and so was it interesting what was
it what was it like what was the fan
Hood like and how they treat fans
different in America and Japan
well it's over in Japan they treat you
like you know your royalty you know it's
just like Brad Pitt and you know Tom
Brady all in one you know what I mean
wow that's how they treat their
wrestlers you know and you know they've
got the sumo wrestlers and they've got
the pro wrestlers and you know there's
even the Sumo wrestles would be bowing
down to us it was just really a strange
situation and stuff yeah did you ever
battle one of those you guys ever I
almost did I almost did because they're
big dudes yeah and they're mostly
bristle right so when you go into the
dressing room at night wherever you're
at there'd be a sheet of paper on the
wall and it was in Japanese writing of
course I knew my name in Japanese you
know Hulk Hogan Ichiban number one and I
would know my name but I couldn't read
who I was wrestling
so all of a sudden the Japanese dressing
room before I started Living and
traveling with the Japanese I was still
with the guy jeans with the Americans
all of a sudden I hear all this crazy
stuff going on next door because the
walls are paper thin over there you know
yeah and all of a sudden Peter Takashi
the referee comes up he goes oh
so-and-so Fuji shoots whatever his name
was just beat up Kabuki the the the the
Booker so this this uh
sumo wrestler who's his first Knight
and apparently the Booker
told this Japanese guy that he wanted
him to put me over but go in and shoot
with me for 10 minutes not work and I'll
take it easy but really go in and shoot
and try to take me down and try to hurt
me but then in the end let me win he
goes no I'm not letting him win
so they come over and tell me that I go
boom you know just go oh no here we go
so I'm going out there bro you know
because that's there is no choice yeah
you got to go out and there was a big
guy there from Vancouver named John
tentacle earthquake I don't know if you
ever remember him earthquake the
wrestler yes yeah I remember he used to
be a sumo wrestler
really good friends he goes no Terry
you're not going out there I am I said
this is all yours brother wow and as
soon as we're watching through the
curtain as soon as tento are out there
this guy tried to hook his eye right
away
and man it pissed down off trying to
beat the out and I was like thank
God I didn't go out there wow because I
would have been ready for him to hook my
eye right away yeah you know I would I
wasn't thinking on that level yeah but
this guy was just really pissed and
didn't you know he came from a sport
where it's a shoot you know in the end
it wasn't predetermined and he did not
want to hear any of putting me over damn
you know he thought he's gonna wrestle
me and beat the crap out of me but sent
John 10 to save me dang so you guys
became friends after that we were
friends before that before the whole
tour I put him over I was hiding behind
him like scared like a mouse you know we
I was droving crazy for the last three
weeks I was with him was there a whole
university you had going on over there
that we didn't even know about yeah yeah
yeah
actually if I was like in Minnesota for
instance
and I would wrestle on a Friday night if
I had Saturday and Sunday off I'd fly to
Japan wow wrestle there in Tokyo and
Osaka didn't fly back for Monday TV
because the money was good there yeah
yeah real good wow yeah Japan we had who
do we have on we had on Jesse Ventura
did you this has already gone better 7
000 times better than that
um Jesse could be a little confrontation
yeah he um he was like I lived you know
I was uh
part of the one percenters
he's like I sat I lived on the seventh
ring of Saturn no yeah you want to know
why oh he hates my guts does he oh bro I
talked to him for three hours I talked
for 17 seconds
yeah he talked for all the other time
and he kept saying I'm Gonna Leave in
just a minute and then he would talk for
70 more minutes wow
it was a trip yeah that guy was just it
was the it was the wildest interview the
chat wildest conversation I ever had in
my whole life well when you go to the
bathroom you close the door behind you
do you
of course yeah you don't want somebody
coming in there and because you're doing
things you're you know you're doing what
God wants you to do you don't need help
but do you do that with your web
browsing
or you leaving the bathroom door open
expressvpn they can help you using the
internet without a VPN is like going to
the bathroom and not closing the door
because your internet service provider
knows every single website you visit
they can sell this information to add
companies and Tech Giants who then use
your data to Target you expressvpn
creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet
so your online activity can't be seen by
anyone it works on phones laptops even
routers so everyone who shares your
Wi-Fi is protected get an extra three
months of expressvpn free by going to
expressvpn.com Theo that's
expressvpn.com
t-h-e-o for three extra months free
Theo I use it I am grateful for it cold
turkey it might be good on sandwiches it
might not it might might not depends on
if you even like it but there's a better
way to break your bad habits than cold
turkey
we're not talking about some Voodoo or
hypnosis we're not talking about that
we're not talking about some crazy
neighbor coming over and just massaging
the the sin right out of you
we're talking about our sponsor fume
and they look at the problem in a
different way
not everything in a bad habit is wrong
so instead of a drastic uncomfortable
change why not just remove the bad from
your habit
fume is an Innovative award-nominated
device that does just that
that's right instead of electronics fume
is completely natural instead of vapor
fume uses flavored air and instead of
harmful chemicals fume uses all-natural
delicious flavors
your fume comes with an adjustable
airflow dial and is designed with
movable parts and magnets for fidgeting
giving your fingers a lot to do which is
helpful for de-stressing and anxiety
while breaking your habit
that's right the taste of fume it's
it's different it keeps you locked in
it's you almost go to it as a little
reward it's your little it's your little
dog treat when you need it and helps you
get over those tough moments
stopping is something we all put off
because it's hard but switching to fume
is easy
fumas served over 100 000 customers
you can join fume in accelerating
Humanity's breakup from destructive
Habits by picking up the journey pack
today head to trifum.com and use code
Theo to save 10 off when you get the
journey pack today
that's
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and use code t-h-e-o to
save an additional 10 off your order
today
um
so whenever uh when you look at a lot of
guys have you know you're in you seem
really healthy you know do you feel
healthier than uh I mean a lot of guys
in your line of work haven't had the
a lot of the same blessings of Health
I mean I know you got a pretty bad spine
you know
um what's bad on you like where's your
health at kind of now
well I think internally I'm healthy it's
just I abuse my body so bad you know
um
in the last 10 or 12 years I've had like
25 surgeries
you know it's kind of weird because when
I went to do Rocky 3 when my mother was
still alive if you would come to my
house
she'd go Yo T come over here first thing
I want to do is measure you you know oh
yeah and that's what she did to me
before I went to do the Rocky movie I
was like 335 pounds I was six foot seven
on the nose well then right before my
mother died a few years back
she wanted to measure me I was six four
and a half you know between the 10 back
surgeries yeah and the two knee
Replacements and the two hip
replacements and the abdominal stuff and
the shoulders and all the surgeries I've
had you know and plus you get older you
shrink up a little bit Yeah you get a
little bit so yeah I mean other than you
know like when I'm with Skye and we're
walking I lean on her so it looks like
we're in high school I'm like hey baby
what's up I'm really just kind of like
hanging on you know for the ride or if
I'm not with her I can pretty much walk
I'm home from here to that door but if
it gets too far than that I get like a
walking stick which is embarrassing and
hell is hell but this guy says embrace
it you're a warrior I said you're right
baby you're right I am a warrior you
know it's a way to look at it yeah so
I'm trying to adapt but
um you know we're going in Monday uh
tomorrow morning for another monogram
you know because I'm having some more
issues with my back and they're going to
see if the disc is pushed in the spine
above the hardware
and if it is then they want to go from
the middle of my backup to my neck but
if the disc isn't pushing on the spinal
cord then they said we don't want to cut
on you anymore and there's because my
left hip is like 25 or 26 years old they
think there might be a problem there but
we're gonna find out yeah but it's all
from that damn fake wrestling basins
nobody told me it was fake
yeah did it get more did it get more
fee like did the theater of it change
over the years how did the theater of
wrestling evolve over the years
I say that when I first got in
um
if you kick somebody leave lace prints
on them
when you punch somebody you know we want
to see black and blue marks yeah that
was the mindset when I was first in and
all and I was a medium-sized guy I was
like 3 10 3 15. I was like medium-sized
sweet Hansen 360 King Kong Mazda 3 360.
all these monsters you know that I was
wrestling and it's you know this hard
pushing them around so
it got to the point where you know these
guys would beat the crap out of each
other and it was real territorial you
know and they'd work four or five days a
week but then once this thing blew up
and I cut a deal with Vince Jr after I
was fired and I came back it was like
every single night there were three
towns a night running you know and so we
kind of lightened up with the work and
it was always supposed to be light but
it never was because people were really
laying it in and really really people
get competitive yeah I mean would there
be guys you had real kind of like you
know yes you had a long day in the car
with him and you're like tonight when we
get out there you're gonna get it it got
a little crazy yeah and you know I
always had a little bit more of a Target
on my back because I was the guy right
you know so oh that's true so if you go
and you break Hulk Hogan's arm guess
what your careers made right and I ran
with the pack a lot but then I'd also
fly to South Africa and wrestle the
heavyweight champion of South Africa and
I'd fly to you know different places
and be by myself yeah you know and Vince
is going don't you lose that belt
monster I'm like oh great you know
because yes you could get hooked real
quick in there you know if you're not
thinking yeah and so there was all that
and then when I come back to the States
I do this wrestle you know and so it was
all cool but it just about
[Music]
um
1980 when I went to Minnesota
instead of digging and wrestling so much
I started you know playing to the crowd
more
and then by the time I came back to New
York to wrestle the Sheik they didn't
play any entrance music they didn't sell
any merchandise I pulled inside I said
bro I'm making a ton of money in the
Twin Cities selling T-shirts and
headbands and Frisbees and all kinds of
stuff and he changed his thoughts and on
the way to the ring donk
the place explodes and stuff just coming
out with no music so I cranked it in the
garden that first night with the Iron
Sheik
no Jimmy Hart my manager sat down and
wrote most of the entrance music for
everybody really he was a musician he
was a composer yeah yeah well he was in
a
way before your time actually before my
time thank God Jimmy's 79 years old but
Jimmy was in a band called The gentrys
and they had a hit song called Keep on
Dancing they recorded at Sun Studios in
Memphis where Elvis recorded oh sweet
yeah been over there yeah and so Jimmy
knew everybody
to record everything you know and not to
record everything but to write
everything yeah yeah write everything
and so yeah once Vince saw the music and
um you know got into the merchandising
and changed the game because you know
when I went up there to work for Vince
Jr
um I lived right next door to him up
there in Greenwich and so I was in the
office every day you know for the first
three or four years it was me and Vince
in the office so you really got dialed
into the business side of it yeah a long
time long time ago before I went back
there right the three years in Minnesota
were a great education for me because I
was with a guy named Vern ganya yeah and
I was real tight with him and his son
owned that area didn't he own that yeah
he owned everything and I was single I
had nothing to do but just learn
you know and plus I just
I just I you know I took to like a duct
of water man I found a way to you know
really you know
progress and generate a ton of Revenue
it was easy for me you know right I had
a feel for it you know and I could
wrestle anybody and I didn't even know
if I was going to wrestle him all he
tells me who's going to want to lose I
don't need to talk about anything I
never talked about a match really except
one time with Rock and we didn't do
anything we talked about
so a lot of times you're out there just
kind of figuring out like you guys each
at a certain point especially if the
guy's good enough for season enough you
know you know you can make it great well
I could go out there with Randy Orton
not sail words matter of fact when I
wrestling SummerSlam we didn't even talk
you know then stole it so he wanted to
win or lose it Randy Orton's old school
yeah I could do that with Cena
you know I'd have to talk listen I mean
you have to I have to lead the match but
I could do it with Cena because he's
good enough yeah um rock all day long
stone cold all day long these guys are
really good in the ring bro yeah flare
all day on me and Flair never talked
nothing to talk about see out there
brother you know so that's how I learned
Andre you know I'd go to Andre hey boss
is there anything I do that dude out
there tonight don't worry
okay well uh you know how do you want to
start the match don't worry okay
scared me to death you know did a guy
like Andre like what kind of like if you
guys were cruising in the car like what
did he have to sit in the back or did he
have to like be under a tarp in the
trunk or the truck or something or how
would you even get like killing me man
but how would you get something that big
somewhere
um well we didn't travel together you
know and
yeah because the car wouldn't go yeah
yeah well we we drove for a lot of years
you know like if I was arrested yeah if
I was wrestling in Atlanta tonight and I
had to be in Minneapolis tomorrow night
I'd drive right no so if you guys drove
like you did if I yeah how could Andre
be in a car could he be in a car
he he they had a van they drove him in
but then we started flying right
early 80s we started flying a lot so it
made it easier but
um if you can imagine there was never a
chair he could sit in he couldn't sit in
that chair couldn't sit there oh yeah
there was never a chair there was never
a bed there was never a knife there was
never a fork he was never comfortable
when he sat on a plane his head would be
sideways like this where the overhead is
he'd be yeah flying like this and every
plane probably just goes to the Bahamas
that he's on you know but the hardest
thing for me was you know
the first eight or nine years he didn't
like me at all and tortured me why was
he jealous well I was I was hard-headed
bro when I was younger I thought I could
beat anybody up and I thought I could
beat him up did you keep that energy
like when you were in person too kinda
like not not he just didn't like me he
just really didn't give me the time of
day but when we got in the ring he
showed me how much he didn't like me
right you know and then I made the
mistake of bringing a flight attendant
to the Capitol Center in Washington uh
we've all done that and I put it right
in the first row and I didn't tell
laundry I didn't tell anybody and then I
kind of kept rolling out of the ring
where she was you know and had Andre
chase me out there and then when he
chased me I turn around and catch him
real quick
and then he heard her saying come on
Terry come on Terry and he goes when he
figured out she was met with me and he
about killed me he took me back in the
ring you know how you tie the ropes up
he tied the bottom rope in the second
and put my neck in and put a size 26
foot on it was just almost broke my neck
in the ropes then I had those yellow
tights on he picked me up like a damn
stork yeah with my balls and my ass
hanging out and carried me around the
ring in front of this girl with all my
junk hanging out yeah
no more girls
yes sir no more girls I get it but you
know he just didn't want that energy
there huh no because you know I was
showing off oh yeah he want to be used
as part of something and I was trying to
get over by showing him off and yeah
beating my ass for that
you know that's awesome dude it's so
much fun
what was up for you maybe yeah that's
true was there a part where it started
to like where where did it start to
because everything I noticed like
there's a there's a part where it's fun
it's beginning and then it becomes work
you know yeah did it start to feel like
that at a certain point I mean even if
you're a hero to the world it's still
yeah I hate it yeah I hated it I hated
the business because of the traveling
and you know the no sleep you have to
make a choice between
eating sleeping or working out so the
prior priorities were working out first
yeah eating and the sleep was the third
priority
so like if we wrestled in Madison Square
Garden tonight
you know and all of a sudden we're
supposed to fly to St Louis
short flight hour and a half singles all
of a sudden you get the LaGuardia planes
canceled
you know oh my God you can't you know an
old story just delayed it just you spent
all days in the all day in the airport
and then when you landed in St Louis you
know do you go to the hotel first and
check in and waste time or do you go to
the gym first so I'd always go straight
to the gym and work out
and then usually I wouldn't have time to
go to the hotel I'd usually go to the
arena
and I was always on last so I'd miss
some room service and food
so that was always a scramble and then
I'd check in the room later at night you
know so it was just a potluck sometimes
the flights would be on time and
sometimes they wouldn't but the
traveling I hated the traveling because
it was I was flying 300 days a year and
it burned you down oh yeah that's brutal
even with stand-up comedy it's like we
get to sometimes you take the overnight
flight because it's the cheapest back
then so sometimes
um when I was living in California we'd
fly so I'd get in at 5 30 you get in at
6 30 in the morning or something so then
they take you straight to radio yeah
right so then you're there for two hours
and then you get back to your hotel now
it's around like 11 A.M but you haven't
slept really so you try to get a few
hours of sleep and then you get up and
want to live it's just that the
traveling Burns people out man yeah you
get off stage last the food call has
already been done oh man I remember
I used to tease John Belushi you know
because we we jump on a blower Friday
night out of uh JFK what do you mean a
blower all night you know oh you mean an
eight ball that guy died in the coke I
think whatever but I I jump on the the
Pan Am you know to go to LA
and we land I'm sorry brother I'll see
you Monday because like he was on the
flight back Monday morning I'd be on it
and you'd see me like this oh man just
beeping this traveling I said since you
got here Friday night bro I've already
been back to New York and back once yeah
I had to fly back to Russell at the
Capitol Center I've been back so since
you've been here resting for 48 hours I
made the trip there and back again he
goes no you didn't I said I swear to God
I did bro you know because you're out of
your mind I said well
so there was a lot of but that's the
part I hated was the traveling
um the only thing that I really dug
was you know being in the ring because
when I was in the ring
you know I was real present
you know I didn't think about anything
else you know Ex-Wives ex-girlfriends
kids business problems money problems
three or four guys that wanted to kill
me in the back I didn't think about
anything you know when I was in the
rails it completely in the moment yeah
you know and when I the one the one
thing that really worked for me was once
I clicked
I was not terrible when I went to that
ring I was Hulk Hogan brother and I
believed it I mean I believed when I was
in there I wasn't afraid of anybody or
anything and I just that was my attitude
you know because if I didn't believe it
you're not going to get them to believe
that they're watching I believed it so I
was so dialed into that character man I
lived through that thing and it got me
through a lot of craziness you know it
helped a lot yeah how tough was it
because you have a family right yeah and
how tough was it um I always wondered
like to your kids like to be because
you're everybody's hero like you were
like you know you were a hero to so many
people right I wonder if it's tough for
a child to be like oh how do I make my
dad seem like my hero you know like
how do I make my dad seem like my hero
if he's everybody else's hero you know I
wonder if that's tough for a kid you
know
I'm sure it is you know
um the kids were real aware of who I was
but you know the moment I would come
home bro that Hulk Hogan thing was
dropped really at the front door I
didn't have any pictures of my house of
Me no wrestling crap in the house at all
I didn't want it in my house some of you
guys have belts hanging and pictures of
themselves but would you ever messed up
with everybody like go to your room and
don't come out to the Bell Rings or
something like would you ever like
no no bro I didn't do that but the thing
was you know I was uh I dropped that
whole cooking Persona and the moment I'd
walk in the house I'd take the bandan
off the bald head and I was just Dad or
Terry and I was you know I could switch
gears pretty easy because I just didn't
live that character like oh yeah brother
yeah Bret Hart thinks he's the greatest
wrestler in all this crazy crap that
these guys think you know I just let it
go man it was a job and I was real good
at what I was doing I had to there had
to be a degree of separation with me
because
you'll end up killing yourself you know
you can't live up to that character I
mean all my guys are dead and I was a
ring leader you know I was a ringleader
I was running them all hard and I'd come
to the edge I'd stop after about four
days you guys keep going I'm out you
know
so it's uh I had I had to draw a line in
the sand
so you were able to do that pretty
pretty it was it came naturally for you
it was pretty easy to do I'm really good
at stopping things or starting things
and
and she's been around me a little while
now but it's beautiful you know she is
she I mean you're handsome
that baby I got me a whole new family
too so I'm good
nice congratulations what are you
talking about
oh you look at her and I forgot what I
was talking about look I feel you I look
I I agree with you just look that's all
you get I'm not gonna look again don't
look again don't look again bro I'm over
here brother yeah cool we're good now
um yeah there's a lot of guys that have
passed away did you go to some of the
guys funerals yeah yeah I quit doing
funerals and weddings because
I walked in on so many hotel rooms where
the guys were passed away you know and
oh over the years just yeah yeah I mean
if you I don't know the numbers now but
you could probably Google one of the
guys could tell you right away but you
know with baseball let's say over the
last 20 years you've already got 20 guys
died or basketball 20 maybe it's 30 or
40. I don't know you know hockey maybe
10 15 20. wrestling 350. yeah I mean
everybody's dead
yeah you know I got a retail store right
down in Clearwater Beach and you know we
sell pictures and posters and I okay
that okay there's six guys in the
picture
I'm the only one still alive it's freaky
man I'm sure you know especially because
my mom and dad are dead and my brother's
dead All My Friends Are Dead so kind of
like the mortality thing can get to you
after a while so when you ask you how
how my health is I'm cool
you know with all the backs I mean you
can have one back surgery and end up in
a wheelchair I've had 10. you know and
so I'm
very blessed very lucky bro you know and
and just uh like I said I mean they're
all in or I'm all the way up if we're in
a party bro we're gonna party yeah if
I'm gonna go straight I'm gonna go
straight you know and right now I'm on
the straight run yeah no alcohol no
actually I did take two Tylenols I was
hurting so bad today but I I didn't take
Tylenols Advil or leave for for months
now and I haven't
drag since January 1st but when I go
nice congrats when I go the other way
you're not swear it gets ugly are you
going in huh oh yeah well flare look I
mean yeah Flair definitely I mean he can
say whatever he wants about me but I put
his ass to bed every time yeah
because he's not a clock vote come on
nine o'clock
yeah he's down last night he invites us
out right so we get out of work we had a
show last night we get out we uh text
his uh the lady has his assistant or
whatever she's like oh he just got now
who's the new victim her name's Gia
she's
I mean I'll tell you this she's uh
she lifts chest a lot I'll tell you that
oh yeah I'll say that typical player
well she skips she skips arm and leg day
but she really
yeah uh and she said oh it's not it he
just went to bed you know I just put him
to sleep but he lives that thing he
usually sneaks off on you though really
I can see it he'll be drinking the bar
drinking the barn you'll think he's
going to the bathroom he don't come back
yeah and there's usually this huge tab
that he leaves so he's got a down
brother
believe me I know yeah yeah that's crazy
short story floor story yeah
yeah
in between back surgery number four five
or six whatever it was I booked this
Hulk Mania tour first time I've ever
booked a tour on my own overseas right
Australia
so I hired Flair and hire a bunch of
wrestlers come with me players I need my
money up front
okay Rick sure all right for one of his
wives I bet he brought one of them with
him yeah actually divorced her right up
he's always got a wife on him somewhere
yeah and so I paid him up front and uh
all sudden we're getting ready to go to
Australia all around my back you know
goes out again and now the tour is
booked I'm following Britney Spears
around I'm a day behind her tour picking
up leftovers yeah
I thought and uh so my background I had
to have another back surgery right
before I left and I had stitches in my
back when I went over there you know
still that's how crazy I used to be you
know you need yeah you need to lay in
bed about six months I was gone let's go
Wednesday we're out of here yeah so I
told Flair yeah thank you yeah so we get
over there and the greatest thing was
the first night in Sydney Sydney
Australia Britney Spears get mad and
shot the crowd of bird right so nobody
came to our tours right the rest of the
tour so we bounced around and picked
everybody up you know and I wrestled
Flair a bunch over there
and every 90 economy goes hey I need
another five grand tonight
what I already paid you oh no I need
another five grand
said okay here's five grand and then he
kept doing I said Rick
why am I giving you five grand well you
know we're drawing such big crowds you
know you you know you need to pay me
another five grand so depending another
five grand I went down to the bar he's
buying drinks for everybody I mean
paying for everything that's what he's
doing with the five grand he's keeping
everybody in the bar to party with him
all night you know and he wasn't going
to bed at nine o'clock back then he
doesn't like to be alone he said he said
there's been times in his life where he
didn't he couldn't absolutely couldn't
stand to be alone yeah I thought it was
interesting yeah because some people
they like their piece they like their
their space
um yeah he just it was interesting even
talking to him he just is who he it
seems like there's
there's not a lot of getting he's just
the Nature Boy that's what he is bro
that's who he is it's very admirable and
it's interesting you know but I mean
that is who he is he likes to have a
good time and he will find it no matter
what and he wants you to have a good
time too
I don't think I could be Hulk Hogan 24
hours a day yeah I don't think I could I
wouldn't make it yeah
well so I can't imagine yeah being a
hero to so many people and how it is
yeah to be able to be then to then be a
dad would also seem like
tough you know
[Music]
um
what about if you could when you look
back on kind of your career because
you've had a lot of different angles
you've had
um wrestling you've had entertainment
right you've had movies we went and I
remember seeing what was one with you
against no holds but yeah No Holds
Barred yeah dude that was crazy
when you did that dude that was a wild
one yeah we went and see you had the
thing and we're like what is going on
here
yeah sorry to see that he's my boy that
wasn't that was a couple years ago right
yeah yeah
yeah do you start to get like why didn't
you why have you had better luck than
some of these guys
I kind of reeled it in bro you mean you
mean why am I still alive yeah it was
after asking me yeah I didn't want to
say it like no no that's cool it's cool
I think honestly
if we stayed up for three four nights in
a row partying I would still go work out
right nobody else would I would still go
train
I would still eat good I was the trading
person vitamins I was actually doing
that you know praying that I wouldn't
die yeah yeah but but the vitamins are
Percocet yeah whatever you know maybe a
couple more but uh
I mean look when they came out with
Somas dude imma drove a car into an
invisible driveway yeah yeah it went
together that was one of the drugs a
choice for the wrestlers yeah it was
very dangerous for them because it would
shut people's throat down my buddy
Richard died he choked on some chicken
that he didn't even know he was eating
and yeah
um but he took some of those muscle
relaxers they relax your throat so much
your it doesn't pull the food down a lot
of people choke today yeah a lot of guys
would get the Soma shakes I don't know
if you ever saw that but that's a little
scary
God it sounds like a tick tock Trend
almost that's just like somebody beating
it just like and they can't stop it
they'll be walking and they freeze and
they I mean I've seen it happen so many
times when you're eating 10 20 of them
at a time you know
but and people were taking that much
pain pills to feel okay huh oh yeah oh
yeah
and uh you know it for me I would always
um
I never went down that road yeah you
know if they're if you're supposed to
take one or two that would be it I never
went down that road five or ten I never
did that you know you didn't have
addiction it doesn't sound like really
no I and you know when it came to weed
or this and that and the other I could
quit not do it for three four five years
it wouldn't matter yeah you know so it's
like
but you know I just think because I was
real consistent with the training and
actually trying to eat good in between
all the craziness or the drinking and
raising hell I kind of like stayed on
track where I would see these guys
defect for weeks and not go to the gym
and just drink constantly and just not
eat and not sleep and I just I can't
handle it man I had to be the lead dog
man right I still had to be the main
event where they could get be on the
match underneath me and be slacking
right I had to I had to blow the road
yeah man to deliver you know I didn't
want anybody stealing my spot because
they were all trying you know every
night yeah I guess it's strange because
your teammates but at the same time
they're low-key trying to take your
throne yeah yeah
they'd be more than happy to replace me
and how much do you have to make sure
the promoter and the owners that you
stay in their good graces so that you
also stay the lead dog is that like a
whole nother thing going on that helps
that helps
um
I just get myself in in a position that
the character
became so powerful even if I really did
piss somebody off they still had to use
me yeah you know because if I went
somewhere else I put them out of
business you know so the character it
had a long run I mean you know oh yes
red and yellow bro through the 80s and
all through the 90s and then then when I
went back you know the last time when I
wrestled the rock and a couple other
people I was still red hot man you know
oh yeah I remember seeing a poster it
said it said Ronald McDonald and
had him yeah with red and yellow and
then it said Hulkamania yeah and that's
when I knew you had just done it yeah
yeah there was there was real a real
iffy thing when I came back to the WWE
the last time because I'd spent 10 years
trying to put him out of business you
know with Ted Turner and we were beating
the crap out of him for a long time
and then there were a bunch of business
decisions in American online internal
broadcasting merged and they didn't want
wrestling as part of their portfolio
they want to turn to Classics new movies
of the week and do programming was that
AOL they merged with that yeah I took my
boss to Turner and kicked him to the
curb
he had some off his way in the back of
the building I couldn't even find him
half the time
and they just didn't want wrestling even
though on TBS and TNT we had three to
one ratings at the highest shows they
had and so when all that started to
decline and demise
um you know I get a call from Vince you
know he says hey man I want you to come
back and you know
put the red and yellow rub on the rock
you know I said well I don't want to
come back as a good guy I'm gonna come
back as Hollywood Hogan you know because
if I'm gonna do it right I want to put
this kid over right you know and plus he
I knew his dad I traveled with his
father for years yeah yeah you guys you
started with the father yeah so it was
Dad we traveled whenever we were
together and I mean I remember when
Brock was like seven or eight years old
I threw my headband and he caught it
crowd of the garden you know so I had a
long history with the family and all the
Samoan brothers and all my guys and
yeah I was there when the rock came back
dude I was there then I came back I
think it was 2014 yeah but anyway go on
so yeah someone arrested you know I did
everything I could to get heat you know
right hit him in the back of the head
with a hammer I put him in an ambulance
chain the ambulance I ran him over with
a semi
I mean I did everything I could to make
people hate me then when I went out of
WrestleMania 18 they cheered me out of
the building whenever the rock would
punch me they'd boo him I was going oh
my God you know so I said all that stuff
we talked about and we ain't doing it
just listen we're going this episode is
brought to you by betterhelp
that's right
I've gotten therapy I've gotten better
help
um you know I've had times where I
wasn't seeing
the world as comfortably as I should be
you know and it wasn't just a little
thing it wasn't just something that I
knew would pass it was something that
was building and gaining momentum inside
of me and it kind of scared me
you know if you're struggling if there's
something that's off it's
I mean we're humans
we have a voice and we need to use that
and we need to get feedback from someone
who knows what they're talking about
better help can help set you up with a
licensed professional
that's right it's entirely online
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time there's no charge
and I want to iterate that if if you are
going to a therapist and it's super
comfortable and easy
but nothing's changing then that might
not be the best scenario
you can always try a new one here or
there you can go back to the first one
if you want
visit betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o today to get 10 off your first
month that's right that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash Theo this episode is
sponsored by betterhelp man it's hot man
it's hot man you know it ask your friend
if it's hot
if they say no they lie
and sometimes it's too hot to cook you
get in the kitchen you can't even start
the oven dying it's more hot
the oven just a box of more hot man
thankfully Factor
America's number one ready to eat meal
kit can help you fuel up fast with
flavorful and nutritious Ready-to-Eat
meals delivered straight to your door
yes
you'll save time eat well and stay on
track reaching your goals
that's the truth if you're too busy with
summer plans to cook or just too heated
out
let Factor help
you don't have to go to the grocery The
Chopping the prepping the cleaning all
that factors got it
looking for calorie conscious options
this summer try delicious dietitian
approved calorie smart meals
with around or less than 550 calories
per serving wow that's great
that's really great
they have 34 plus weekly restaurant
quality options like bruschetta shrimp
Rosado
Greek goddess chicken oh hey and grilled
steak filet mignon
ready in just two minutes they have keto
to calorie smart vegan and veggie
Protein Plus they've got it all
this July get factor and enjoy eating
well without the hassle simply choose
your meals and enjoy fresh flavor-packed
meals delivered to your door already in
just two minutes no prep no mess head to
factormeels.com
theo50 and use code 3050 to get 50 off
that's code theo50 at factormeals.com
d050 to get 50 off man hydration is key
I was just talking with my uh
with my kind of step dad
adoptive stepdad and he was telling me
um that he's he had to go to the
hospital kid wouldn't get hydrated
so they started hitting him up with
hydration
and so I'll send them over some uh
liquid IV
I said hit these packets Cat Daddy
stay well baby
stay dripping
liquid IV the number one powdered
hydration brand in America is now
available sugar free
and that was a lot of people's issues
sometimes with these things too much
sugar
but years in the making now the
hydration multiplier sugar-free uses a
proprietary zero sugar hydration
solution with no artificial sweeteners
that's just hydration only
with three times the electrolytes of the
leading sports drink plus eight vitamins
and nutrients for everyday Wellness
liquid IV hydrates two times faster than
water alone
they got three new flavors white peach
white peach grape grape and lemon lime
that's it one stick of liquid IV and 16
ounces of water hydrates you two times
faster and more efficiently than water
alone yep
real people real flavor real hydrating
now sugar-free grab your liquid IV
hydration multiplier sugar-free in bulk
nationwide at Costco or get 20 off when
you go to liquid iv.com and use code
Theo at checkout that's 20 off anything
you order when you use promo code Theo
at liquid iv.com so I guess in the end
the crowd is the real determinant yeah
if whatever script they're writing if
it's gonna play or not yeah Ah that's so
interesting yeah because you know like I
said we'd never
um
I'd never talked to anybody about having
a match before and when I went back
Vince was worried well things have
changed monster you know if you're gonna
come back here you gotta really bring it
I didn't say anything but in my mind I'm
saying if I bring my you're gonna
ask me to take it back
you know because I can still go
and so I didn't say anything and then
all of a sudden I get a call from Vince
you know we really feel comfortable if
you go down to Miami and rehearse the
message events I've never rehearsed a
match in my life what do we even talk
about yeah I don't know what I'm going
to do until I listen to the people
you know this with my ear and my heart I
don't yeah you know so we I got out of
respect Vince asked me to go down there
so I go down there and Rocky Johnson's
there's Dad
oh yeah he played football at Miami
didn't he yeah and it's hot as a
in this Warehouse it had middle of
summer and this other guy named Pat
Patterson who knows a lot about
wrestling and kind of helped me when I
first started so I get in the ring of
The Rock and he kind of told me what he
wanted to do you know and kind of walk
me through what he wanted to do and I
was thinking man if
you know what if the crowd doesn't like
what we're doing are we just gonna keep
doing this
you know a lot of respect I listened to
him you know yeah because you know it
was dad and him and the family I listen
to everything I want to do and then Pat
Patterson goes okay let's go through the
match I said are you crazy
so if I fall down here I'm gonna get
hurt yeah I need 80 000 people bro you
know I mean I'm a one-time around the
block guy yeah me too dude
a lot of times I said look just we're
cool and Dwayne's fault I mean Rock's
father's going Dwayne listen to Hogan
he's just yelling at him from outside
just listen to Hogan you know so we get
up to Toronto right
and you know everybody thinks I'm gonna
get booed out of the building and
they're going to cheer him because he's
been the number one Babyface guy there
forever so we're in the dressing room
and The Rock starts going over what we
kind of plan I'm listening and listening
okay brother Sarah we'll do it if it's
there we'll do it if it's there we'll do
it and his dad's going Dwayne listen to
Logan so we get out there bro and it was
boonham cheering me I said ah this ain't
gonna work so we kind of flipped things
around in the ring and he was so good in
the ring bro he's like an audible man
he's like that second generation third
generation wrestler Instinct man he was
there so it was fun but it took me about
10 minutes to get things turned around
yeah to where they were pissed at me and
halfway pissed at me and you know
halfway for each of us so but it was it
was a an amazing night I've never
experienced anything like that with a
crowd that was that was a lot of clip
thinking on our feet out there that's
cool man but that's how it always was
with me I never wanted to talk about
anything I want to go out there and see
what these people want please start
deciding for them oh I remember
screaming so loud I thought you could
hear me through my television you know
well you know what that what you're
talking about that main event
laundry we had 33 million people watch
that night
still the largest TV audience for NBC
dude oh I can't imagine how many younger
siblings
are in wheelchairs because of you guys
oh thanks brother and look and proudly
in wheelchairs too thanks brother I mean
can we get some class action lawsuits
thanks brother I remember once wrestling
came on I knew to put on my knee in
elbow pads because I was a young kid
because I was a younger brother dude and
we were gonna get it brother man that's
cool what's been a tough thing like a
lot of you guys travel so much a lot of
it's tough on families what's the top
what was the toughest part like uh was
it tough on your family with I'm sure
with the dad being gone it's got to be
really tough you know looking back was
there ways you think that you could
manage it better or like flair said the
career just takes so much time you just
can't be home I had kind of this just
sounds terrible to say but I have to say
it I had a luxury that a lot of guys
didn't have
I kind of like got myself in a position
where
like if I took time off for a movie
Vince oh my God I can't write your name
down it's hard to book
because you know Vince had a book old
school book and he put Hogan versus
Kamala or Hogan versus Andre the Giant
and then you know there's a b and c town
There's the A-Town I was on the b-town
The Warriors on C-Town would be like a
tag team
[Music]
everybody want to be on the A-Town you
know because if you're in the first
match in my town you make like two three
five thousand dollars you're making
money and if you're in the Sea Town you
know the first match you'd make 250 or
350. yeah
so Vince would go oh man you know it's
just so hard to book when you take time
off to do a movie or whatever like I did
16 or 17 for a bunch of kids movies you
know on TV series and all kind of weird
stuff but
you know so I I put most of my time in
in the luxury that I was afforded was
the character was so powerful honestly
you could put my name down I said it
don't even matter just put my name down
and say Hulk Mania is coming to
Washington DC if you want to put an
opponent they're fine but you don't have
to and and the the character was so
powerful as far as the drawing power
that
once my daughter Brooke was about two
not about three years old and she
started noticing I was gone I started
winding down a little bit and I started
working more part-time but I was
chartering planes all the time right so
you're using your time right so if I was
Four Square Garden one night and I had
Tuesday off I'd fly home right and then
Wednesday it had to be in Mexico City I
fly to Mexico you know and it got to the
point where
I had to buy my own plane you know to
get this done oh wow you were really
doing some business yeah yeah I was
doing real good
and um you know so I when my kids got up
and Nick was two years behind so by the
time Brooke was four or five and Nick
was two or three I started to slow down
so I spent a lot of time at home you
know the last 15 or 20 years of my
career but I still banged it out man I
still had some crazy deals going where I
still generated a lot of Revenue yeah
and did you have full ownership of your
own of your own character how did that
work out with
because it's you create it within the
WWF yeah right so was there Partnerships
in it and stuff like that
you ready for this story maybe if it's
uncomfortable no no it's way cool it's
just really a little twister
I own everything I own Hulk over my own
whole community on holster
congratulations I want a few few guys
that are on their name and the rights
and the trademarks and licenses I own
everything yeah so when I first the name
I was wrestling I had several names
Super Destroyer Terry Boulder Sterling
golden Terry the whole Boulder different
Sterling golden sounds no offense I know
what you but yeah I don't love that one
I don't know well that was a guy named
Jim Barnett who's a very nice man yes
that was cool yeah he was cool
you know okay it's a little light in the
loafers but he's a good guy hey yeah
loved him to death but um yeah he called
me Sterling oh yeah that's what I'm
saying dude that freaked me out man yeah
but anyway yeah so anyway I went through
all these different things and finally
when I quit and I was working on the
docs I'll Never Wrestle again I'm done
I'm you know five or six times I've quit
I'm over this crap
I get a call from Vince McMahon and it's
a couple local wrestlers Jack and Jerry
Briscoe who are here in Florida Jack was
his NCAA Champion World Heavyweight
Champion loyal wrestlers yeah they said
you know Vince McMahon
this is perfect for you this is Madison
Square Garden this is all the really big
wrestlers go
and they kept pounding on me pounding on
me I said okay well I'll go up there but
I'm not taking my wrestling stuff with
me like
what kind of a horse's ass is that
so I fly up there and they had just got
rid of Superstar Billy Graham because he
kind of like they had some problems with
him
[Music]
330 pounds I was working on the docks
running game on the doc's arm wrestling
everybody stuff so I walk up there in
the whole building's I can't slid
through the building I didn't know how
to get in correctly so I had to cut
through the crowd for about 20 or 30
feet and the whole building started you
know superstar superstar I thought it
was Billy Graham oh I had a tie-dye tank
top on I didn't even think about it and
Vince McMahon senior goes don't you ever
wear that tie-dye in here again I guess
he just had a blowout with Billy Graham
so anyway I met with him and
he talks about what they wanted to pay
me you know because I I just get tired
of getting screwed over and they talked
about getting me a place to live and
having a guy travel with me which was
the one of the worst decisions ever made
that hooked me up with one of the
biggest con men ever really I don't know
if you know who or Banner was yeah
Captain Lou Albano his partner Tony
altamore they were the Sicilians Tag
Team Champions I remember Tony okay well
Tony was
the biggest car you ever met wow he
taught me everything how to slip and
fall in a grocery store and we'll have
two three grand how to do everything you
know yeah so it just it was horrible to
put me with him but smart me up what the
world's all about
so anyway as I'm talking he goes you
know what I want you to be Hulk Hogan I
said well what does Hulk Hogan mean he
goes like that I haven't posted for the
Polish Americans Bruno San Martino for
the Italian Americans Chief Jay Strong
both for the Native American Indian
Americans
and I want you to be Hulk Hogan for the
Irish Americans here's two bottles of
red dye I want your hair red
and you know and they put me with Fred
blasty
and I told Fred I said brother I'm going
bald-headed as it is if I put this red
diamond here the party's over so if dog
goes down the toilet oh my God he's
gonna fire us I could care less and they
didn't fire me yeah but that's how I get
the name right Hulk Hogan to represent
the Irish Americans dang and Vince gave
you the name
so now Vince died the Irish goodbye that
could have been your finishing move ooh
strong brother I like that sorry that
would have been really good not trying
to tell you what to do but it could have
been neat because but what you did work
great yeah
so anyway Vince dies Vince his son takes
over and right when this Hulk Hogan
thing takes off we get a call from
Marvel Comics you're infringing on Mark
reasonably similar Lou ferrigno's
character the with the cartoon character
Incredible in the magazine is before the
TV series right you know your infringing
on our Mark we're gonna sue you put you
in litigation so
we went ahead and and let them have the
name
didn't license the name but they only
had I only had to pay him one tenth of
one percent oh wow so out of a dollar if
I get a penny I had I only had to pay
him one tenth of a penny and that went
from 85 to 2005. 20 years
fast forward to 2005.
it's over you know and like now I can't
use Hulk Hogan in there and I'm red hot
in 2005 man I'm still jamming so into my
attorneys I don't give a damn what deal
you make you're going to make that deal
because I need the name so what happened
was we went and I got a one-year
extension
I had to pay on 30 of everything I made
movies TV wrestling they got 30 of
everything but
if they decided to sell the name they
had to give me first shot at it they
couldn't you know sell the name or do
anything you know right at a fair market
value so all of a sudden Marvel Comics
gets in a fest with the WWE about
intellectual properties that they can't
re-air old Hulk Hogan matches which
means was re-airing on this stuff they
lost Marvel Comics lost and the events
like uh 35 million dollars and they made
a huge mistake of including that in the
deal and they said no instead of paying
you 35 million dollars how about if we
give you the Hulk Hogan name and I heard
about it and I went you guys screwed up
now because now I don't have to pay 35
million dollars for the name you have to
sell it to me at a fair market value
which is only like 750 Grand wow yeah so
I bought the name backer and Vince
wanted to buy the name for me nah I
think I got this let me get this yeah I
got this one wow did that feel pretty
yeah that must have been a cool moment
because then it's almost like you own
yourself yeah so I bought the name back
and I just own everything
oh congratulations yeah it's really hard
to do in these and then yeah how many
guys you know that have that can say
that yeah
was there ever some products like people
sometimes will try to get me involved
with different types of things you know
have there been interesting products or
something you got or things that you got
involved with like I did some pyramid
scheme or I I lost money in pyramid
schemes when I was younger but
um but that was just like somebody tried
to do like a somebody sold us like
glitter mining or something like yeah
some guy came in our town and said they
were selling like
some shares of like glitter mining or
something but
um have you ever had crazy products over
the years you're like what the what
is this that we're even doing well I
mean we've I mean you've had a lot of
very successful stuff but if ever just
been anything crazy like we're gonna
make Hulk Hogan like Ferris wheels or
something and you're like well
I mean I think I've had like 70 or 80
action figures made yeah I got a couple
at the uh in my childhood room yeah well
the one they made to kind of got a
little wonky and got a little weird was
they made a Hulk Hogan vibrating action
figure which got real funky you know and
brother yeah yeah I got a little scary
brother
now look if you keep one for the lady
okay
and I didn't look at I didn't say
nothing sir I don't even know what's
over there
what do you guys do for fun dates now
because you guys seem like you have a
nice Rapport what do you guys like to go
do together
um we love to eat yeah we love to eat
um we used to love to drink but that's
over
for now
um I just love spending time with him
man I'm a beach bum I lived on the beach
my whole life the only reason I leave
the beach is to make money now you can't
get me off this beach yeah I'll just
live right up the street maybe two
blocks oh that's awesome yeah so um yeah
it's a really clear I've never been to
Clearwater before I know I heard crazy
stories that John Daly used to live in a
Hooters here yeah did you never know
about that yes yeah yes I know atrocity
got her own suitors oh that's cool yeah
yeah I always heard that he used to live
inside of a Hooter somewhere and that
always
that's funny there's some great stories
about him and Jon Gruden
um yeah Gruden was across the street
does he yeah those apartment series of
the penthouse over there he's a really
neat guy that's cool it's cool he's
pretty intense dude
he's a good guy yeah I just know him
from being around here I mean I've got
him back home a couple times you know
he's been out running around so
you know make sure he's home safe oh
yeah yeah he's a good guy yeah it was
funny you um
if you said you quit drinking I haven't
drank let me see 14 months I'm 14 months
sober so I don't do drugs or alcohol but
um
uh what made you quit were you just her
taking a break
I've been with my girl Skye for a while
and everything that I've ever had
happened in my life both of my two
marriages everything that's ever bad
happened to me has had to do with
alcohol oh yeah you know and during
those marriages there was
a lot of alcohol use at times which
cause major issues major problems
and so
um
for me it was really easy to eat a
couple Percocets and drink a couple
shots tequila and a couple
eight percent white closet okay brother
I'm ready yeah and but then you know
when I get with Skye I started
getting an Ezra you know if things
weren't said correctly or I didn't like
these things sounded I would pick you
know I'd kind of like dig and start
and all of a sudden I started losing
something I didn't want to lose again so
I said I'm done drinking that it made it
made just communication a little bit
hectic at times Well it made me not go
off like a Hot Pocket whenever I didn't
hear something I didn't like it you know
because I was I'm I could be very
well we're not doing I could be a prick
yeah you know and real quick on the
trigger finger especially the men yeah
you know and men have probably tried you
a lot over the years huh because you
were I've had some issues Yeah but I
I gotta tone my thing down you know I'm
tired of getting sued all the time you
know so yeah the main thing was that is
there other stuff that you want to do
with your life you've had a really
amazing life do you feel like it went by
so fast sometimes or do you have when
you look back on your life like and you
still have you I mean you could still
probably live for another 25 years you
know but or maybe 30 I don't know you
could live forever maybe I don't know
what your plan is but
um do you feel like did you ever was it
like you were always looking for like a
sense of accomplishment or what do you
think like was like you're driving force
a lot of the times
probably the thing that really pushed me
more than anything was you know I didn't
want to do the what was me story but
I grew up
and I didn't know we don't even want to
say poor I don't even want to say that I
grew up not knowing that we didn't have
money you know my mom was a housewife
my dad were construction
and I had one bicycle got stolen I never
got another one yeah and I had two
little trucks to play with I still had
this little pink truck that I had and I
had a big yellow Tonka trunk truck and I
played with that in the door all day
because my dad was a construction worker
yeah and so I kind of grew up you know
and then when I got older I realized you
know once a month on a Friday we had one
of those little minute Stakes you know
and I just kind of grew up and I started
realizing you know looking around that
okay
you know I guess they did the best they
could
but I don't want to live like this when
I grow up so I had this crazy thing I
didn't even know it was an affirmation I
started telling myself money comes quick
and easy to me and I just kept would
always say that in my head and I said
I'm not gonna die the poor Tampa death
because in Tampa there's a road called
Gandy Boulevard
and if you're south of Gandy or SOG
south of Gandy okay and I grew up south
of Gandhi and everybody from south of
Gandy either becomes a professional
athlete or a drug dealer or you die or
you were construction your whole life
yeah I didn't want to die the poor Tampa
death right you know you wanted to get
knocked you wanted to get on the other
side right so I wanted to fight my way
out of that town yeah I didn't want to
be a drug dealer I didn't want to die I
didn't want to work construction because
I tried construction as a it
wasn't me yeah okay so I said I'm gonna
fight my way out of this town you know
plus I played music so I would do
anything to avoid working a real job
yeah okay so I played music for 10 years
and did real well at that but then it
got to the point where
I was playing the same clubs and just
it's just am I gonna do this forever
right you know and so I just switched
gears and went after the wrestling thing
you know and uh
it took me a while to adapt to it you
know yeah it sounds like that but I was
pretty aggressive when I was a kid you
know and I just uh kept pushing you know
I made the big mistake of telling
everybody in this town I was going to be
a wrestler did you really yeah yeah
that's what my leg broke the first day
but that's such a scary you know who did
that The Miz I'm friends with The Miz
right and hey by the way yeah that
brother was keep this art form alive
every time I see him I tell him I wish I
love him yeah for what he's done but
because he he understands his business
a lot more than most of the guys do
there's probably two or three guys that
I can pick out that understand that
business he's one of them yeah and he
gets it he lives I mean he's always been
that I remember him telling us before he
was arrested he's like I'm going to be a
wrestler and we thought he was crazy and
then he proved us all wrong dude I was
oh I was down in Ybor City
and there was an old truck uh Blues
image called Ride Captain Ride an old
song I just walked over the other studio
and laid the scratch bass line down for
Mike Panera in the Blues image band way
before your time but then I went back
over to the studio and we had a chance
to go on a national tour with Blackfoot
you know and I just came off tour with
this lady named Jeannie Conroy and we
and we we came back to the studio and
everybody was screwing around one guy
was getting married and one guy's
girlfriend was having a baby and so we
get we can leave in two weeks and go on
the road with these guys and Mother's
Finest I don't know if you know who they
are that song CM Punk comes out to the
whole personality that band mothers oh
yeah
we were going to go with them in
Blackfoot we were going to open for him
I said brother this is our chance
because our shit's straight right now
two of the guys didn't want to leave
and I was so pissed off so let me
tell you guys something I'm done
I've been doing this for 10 years I've
been doing this for 10 years with a
couple of you guys
and I'm done I'm quitting and I'm gonna
go be the greatest wrestler that ever
lived and all five of these guys fell on
the ground laughing they busted out
laughing
and it pissed me off so bad I didn't
know what I was talking about I just
said it because I was mad at him because
they wouldn't run the road yeah and then
I said okay damn it I'm gonna go be a
wrestler you know it's just the whole
thing was crazy I had a couple
altercations with wrestlers in bars and
had met a few of them so I wasn't scared
to death him like I was
because back in the 70s you know I'd
probably fire hers and teeth knocked out
and noses bro I was scared to death for
wrestler yeah because back in the day
when Eddie Graham here had the promotion
he said Russell was fake they'd punch
you right in the mouth wow I mean there
was no lawsuits no lawyers or nothing
like that yeah I love that I wish I was
alive so like I was scared to death him
but then I kind of got used to seeing
them come in the bar because we had a
really hot local band at the time they
would come in to hear us play
you know and then I kind of would watch
him and I wasn't so afraid of him you
know as I used to be
but yeah just all changed man
was your see your father did
construction did were you at one time
able to like say hey Dad you don't have
to work anymore was he always a worker
his whole life
yeah well the sun the sun burned him up
bro because he worked outside here in
the Florida heat oh God he started out
in the Panama Canal was where he met my
mother my father's Italian my mother's
Panamanian oh cool man yeah so I don't
have to really go in the sun too often
yeah my father's from Nicaragua so there
you go I have to be careful how I say
that word but also I I don't have to go
in the sun all the time if you go out
for 10 minutes you turn awesome
yeah I'm on that team
yeah so you know it's kind of like um
what was the question
um was your father pretty proud of you I
guess a good question it got to a point
where
uh my family was kind of like
not the most
feely touchy loving family you know oh
yeah you know I had a couple Brothers I
had one half brother and then
another little brother that uh
didn't do too well in life you know and
he got killed he was riding with a bunch
of motorcycle clubs and stuff and didn't
do too well but um
you know my dad and mom I don't ever
ever remember my dad you know really
being affectionate until later on in
life you know when I started doing good
and I quit college after four years
which I should add a degree but I quit
go play music again and that really
didn't work too well probably made him
nervous huh
yeah and then when I told him I was
going to be a wrestler that really upset
you know and then later on
um I brought him up to Madison actually
the night I beat the sheath I brought my
mom and dad up wow to Madison Square
Garden to see that and my dad had just
retired so I just uh
from that point on I just paid for
everything and then when my brother um
got killed I was real young at the time
and I got three kids you know that were
his his wife got murdered first oh here
it's in the motorcycle gang guy yeah
yeah my brother was riding with a club
and he'd done a couple years in Rayford
here and then when he got out he got in
trouble here and he moved to Houston
changed the name and then he was riding
with the I don't even want to say the
club but the Oakland chapter in
California but while he was riding in
Oakland
um
his wife was running a hotel management
hotel and she was dating this mafia guy
and she was on the Dance Floor after
work just dance with the customer came
and shot it in their chest twice killed
her so then shortly after that my
brother had a little problem with one of
the clubs and they killed him
and so um
actually it's not true he died of an
overdose and nobody helped him that's
the real truth I don't want to say it
that way but um
so I ended up with three kids you know
kind of like having to support him right
and so I was running so hard I had to
let my parents help and then the other
side of the family helped but I was the
guy right now and taking care of the
kids and and my parents so well she had
a lot of responsibility then suddenly to
really to be the uh guy who's helping
Finance keep things going basically I
couldn't quit wrestling anymore okay
yeah I had to make it work I had to make
it work so it's it's been a test you
know test of faith
so you know it's all good did y'all have
did y'all go to church and stuff growing
up or was there any faith in y'all's
home
I went to uh Ballast Point Baptist
Church well I went to Ballast Point
Elementary School over in South Tampa
and I went to Ballast Point Baptist
Church with my mom once
and then uh one of my buddies was there
that I went to elementary school and I
started going with his family every
Sunday oh yeah you know did they have
donuts and stuff over there yeah for
everything God I love that dude the Lord
will freaking get you with that yeah and
so I didn't get it because I was so
young but then later on I was like 13 or
14 years old I was playing guitar
a buddy of mine who I played football
with in junior high school he had a
a little Christian Youth Group and uh he
said we need somebody to play guitar so
I went up there with this guy named Hank
Lindstrom and I started playing guitar
and then that's when I started listening
to scripture and then when I heard the
John 3 16 God slowly gave only the son
that whoever believes in him shall not
perish but have everlasting life
bam it hit me you know
and I accepted Christ as my savior when
I was 14 you know saved but then of
course I derailed yeah for a long time
you know and uh went back and forth to
church every once in a while and
um my first life with the Catholic and
that really wasn't my thing you know my
kids went to a Catholic school and went
to a Catholic Church I just I didn't
feel it didn't resonate with me and then
my second wife
was spiritual but she wasn't a Believer
so that didn't work for me
and so this lady here is on the team so
we go to church every Sunday oh nice and
uh
um
it's a Christian Indian Rocks Christian
Church
and uh it's nice having faith huh
actually I took a buddy of mine with me
today a guy named Mel chancy he was the
uh
the president of Hell's Angels chapter
from Chicago
I was a one percenter yeah I took him
and he was this guy was too yeah oh yeah
sorry Ventura just told me that so many
times yeah yeah but Mel you know
and he went with you guys today yeah
he'll tell you the story he told my
Minister that he went away for nine
years oh he was incarcerated yeah for
Rico and for a couple attempted murders
and then he he came out and he found
the Lord
and uh we reconnected so I took and he's
got his own little Ministry thing on the
internet he does really what's it called
Mel chances yeah melchan she's John 3 16
devotional okay is that the name of
above John 3 16 devotion I have to check
him out is he pretty cool
oh you're digging bro he's straight man
he's really cool well it's interesting
because a lot of you a lot of
some of them were almost like pastors to
us as kids they were you know it was
like it's where you got your message of
hope you know I think that's a lot of
what faith is for people I know it is
for me you know it's like where do I get
a message for hope you know and
um and yeah sometimes just hearing like
yeah somebody like you can do it you
know like take your vitamins say your
prayer you know like or just anything
that inspires like where do you find
your hope as you go along through life
you know and a lot of times for when we
were kids it was I mean wrestling is
really what hit me first
um it was probably my most favorite
sport until I started watching UFC yeah
um yeah which I really love you know UFC
is awesome do you ever watch any of that
yeah yeah there was there's an
opportunity to buy it a long time ago
and since I passed on it you know it was
uh before the referee stopped things
yeah and they were kicking people when
they were on the ground and it just was
so violent when it was brought to us we
went
and uh
that was a huge mistake
but yeah no it's uh
yeah so many guys you know that I know
you know finally start believing more in
the Unseen than the scene and they and
they kind of like figured this life out
you know yeah hopefully not too late but
uh it's pretty amazing once you kind of
figure it out yeah
well it's nice to not feel alone I think
you know I think a lot of people are
looking for that these days you know I
wonder like societally have we taken
like I wonder if our society will look
back and be like what a weird detour we
took like thinking that we could find
happiness in so many different things
you know I don't know I like thinking
about that stuff sometimes no it's
pretty crazy man a lot of people just
in this human Incarnation bro they're
just all about materialistic stuff you
know yeah and uh
as soon as they have a glitch with their
health or something they change it right
away yeah you know oh definitely you'll
start drawing pictures of the Lord
immediately huge yeah man I'll get a
couple bag and one bad blood test dude
and I'm on you know I'm on bible.org or
whatever there you go
um
what um do you guys take any vacations
you and your lady have a vacation plan
for the summer we don't have one yet I
guess you live in a vacation yeah we do
we don't have one yet we're talking
about
going some places last year on her
birthday we were gonna go to Miami but I
was sick as a dog or something but you
know we've got uh we're planting some
stuff now things are kind of
straightened out it's been a really busy
year this last year has it been yeah
it's been crazy man
decided to go back to work again
are you but you're gonna wrestle again
no no no no but I mean business-wise
okay understood I mean nothing no
disrespect to Bo and Darren Prince and
stuff but they can they can tell you you
know or anybody that you know
they called me for stuff all the time
and I think in the last couple years
I've made just like one appearance yeah
maybe maybe one but you know I did one
this year already
but that for years and years they'd call
me to do stuff and you know don't just
wasn't interested well I once I shut
down I shut down brother you know yeah
because this I'm I'm like a beach bum
you know I'm not really into it good for
you you know so I mean it's kind of like
I've turned down a bunch of movies a
whole bunch of movies whole bunch of
TV I mean you know T I get calls all the
time yeah TV yeah because you know with
the content I have now with the bar in
the restaurant the retail store here in
the retail store in Orlando my son's
back here and my daughter's here and my
new baby here's got three kids and and
there's there's all kind of content bro
and everybody's banging me all the time
to do reality shows and stuff and I'm
just like
I just shut it all down and even with
appearances and autograph sessions you
know I mean I use vo and Prince
marketing you know when I do do stuff
and
you know sometimes the WWE will call me
to do stuff and I'll just come on I
still work for him you know and you know
I'll kind of pass on that and or I'll do
it you know it just depends on
what the weather's like you know yeah
out back
oh yeah but no no I got in business with
Tyson and uh all these guys to you know
for this whole Wellness thing that we
we're moving forward on you guys have a
CBD line is that right we do we do when
does it come out Bo help me
August okay yeah and this is some of the
packaging stuff man you know oh sweet
let me see yeah so it's uh we're going
for uh
oh nice is a vape yeah
yeah we're going for the whole Wellness
aspect of it because after yeah boy
after being in so much yeah what is you
gonna do yeah sorry what if it meant
what if every time I hit it it made it
so that's how I talked bro it would work
that would be awesome it would work dude
this is a Vibe man yeah because the the
ones they have are so generic I've Vaped
on and off for about a year and a half
so yeah I've been at the bottom of one
of these boy I've been through
it all
no I can't even sleep
yeah this thing will make you
drive all night
you're too much man so if it's Wellness
like what type of stuff so CBD yeah well
we got CBD for you know energy and for
sleep and we're also going down the THC
Road okay yeah because there's so many
people
that got hooked on prescription pain
pills and prescription drugs and
different drugs to sleep you know
halcyons and Xanax that you know it
seems like you know going down down that
road with the THC is an option for
people safe healthier option you know
yeah and so you know I partnered with
and you know and what I didn't
understand at the time is to sell the
THC you know you have to partner with
somebody from the same state starting
yeah I didn't know that you know so if
you're in Michigan you got to partner
with a grower in Michigan so in Florida
we partnered with sunburn and they've
got 150 dispensaries around the state
and we start August 1st with them so I'm
really excited because you know it's
kind of like a it's a gradual transition
it's a way to back out slowly
uh from you know stuff that can be
really addictive yeah which is the perks
the pain pills whatever else you know
people you know numb themself with the
alcohol and everything else so I just
think it's a more realistic way to wind
down and get healthier so I'm on the
team man I'm really excited about it and
will it will you be like featured on
their products is it like Hulk's meta is
it like a yeah it's going to be Hulk's
uh
Hulk's uh products yeah okay and then
we're gonna going to uh with the Delta
eight and a couple things we came up
with a
a kind of cool little thing like kind of
like an inside joke that you know when I
was the bad guy Hollywood Hogan we were
always riding dirty yeah we always had
beer in the car we were partying in the
car I mean National doing all kind of
crazy stuff so when you go with
Hollywood Hogan you know and you're
gonna go ride dirty we're gonna have
something called the mustache rides oh
yeah absolutely ride dirty get a
mustache ride with Hollywood I've given
a call I think I've given a couple I
don't even know what it is I have to
Google it need to grow the mustache bro
okay well yeah those are lip rods oh
yeah there we go yeah those are lip
fries too yeah those are front teeth
rods some of them I'm really I'm pretty
uncoordinated so
um that's awesome though congrats man
yeah so it should be interesting to see
uh you know how my brand performs yeah
Arena well I'm sure look and anything
you've gotten into you've performed well
so I'm sure this shouldn't be different
yeah what makes sense you know it's a
it's a logical extension of where I'm
going and where I've already been so
just the whole thing makes sense at this
point you know everybody's kind of aware
on how much this will help you know
certain individuals and get some healing
yeah thank god brother thank God but
yeah I love them uh but that's nice you
have your whole family here now yeah
yeah your whole family's in town Nick
moved back yeah and he helps me a lot
well he's real good on the stick man he
runs Monday nights for us I don't know
if you're around tomorrow uh I might
actually be staying till Tuesday so if I
do you have to come to my bar tomorrow
night
okay it is insanity really it is insane
what goes on in there I mean karaoke is
unbelievable isn't it well
my partner said karaoke wouldn't work I
said that depends on who's doing it bro
yeah you know so it gets really sick
over there and yeah they got some real
singers in this town huh well it's
either really good or it's really bad oh
yeah it's not in between so yeah but if
you're around please come over man yeah
maybe I will because I think I'm gonna
stable I was gonna go maybe right across
the street yesterday no we're staying in
uh we got shows in Tampa one more
tonight okay
but I wanted to come to the beach
tomorrow so maybe I would make that work
and I wouldn't leave till Tuesday
no that'd be cool yeah
who's somebody that you missed wrestling
or just spending time with like who's
somebody that like that you miss
well I mean across the street there used
to be right where my restaurant's out
across the street that Plaza right next
door to it there used to be a gym
upstairs and The Bushwackers had a gym
up there oh really so for a long time
the Russells would come there and then
right down the street there was a
World's Gym
and during the 80s and 90s every morning
there would be like 30 or 40 wrestlers
in there wow and they all lived up and
down the beach you know I'd bring them
here to hang out for a couple days next
year I knew they'd move it was like
crazy you know and then the whole
wrestling was based out of here for a
long time yeah all the travel from
Connecticut everybody's flying out of
Tampa it was like crazy to go to Tampa
Airport unless you see 20 or 30 guys on
the same plane you know wow but my guys
that were here all the time that I
really missed was Randy the Macho Man we
were together every single day were
y'all really yeah every day man and it's
kind of like I miss him a lot you know
and so I spent years and years and years
with him and he used to babysit my kids
for me he did yeah or him and Elizabeth
yeah but uh something not just Randy him
and Liz but yeah and the other the other
brother that I missed was one of the
Road Warriors Hawk oh yeah I introduced
him to his wife here you know she was a
was Hawk the longer hair he had that no
he had the two yeah and he well yeah
well they both were the spikes yeah God
they were good man yeah and and so Hawk
was a Minnesota boy and when I was in
Minnesota
you know I used to train at a gym with
Brad Riggins the the head Olympic coach
and Brock Lesnar used to come down and
work out with us back in the day and
another guy named Kevin Kelly who was a
real tough kid man and so I would tell
those guys I'd tell Lesnar I tell Kevin
Kelly look bro I'm the main event guy
yeah Brad Riggins the Olympic coach he's
in the preliminary match so you guys
beat him you can try me you know so Brad
saved me from these guys right you know
but I used to watch Brad torture him you
know it was great so wow yeah so Hawk
was up there in Minnesota when I was
training up there he was just some high
school kid in the gym
him and him and animal you know they
watch us like Hawks and watch us like
Hawks next thing I knew I come back like
two years later and go to that gym and
they're jacked up they've each gained
100 pounds I was like holy crap yeah you
know we're gonna be wrestlers I said
good luck don't touch me you know and
they went down to Atlanta and broke in
and they had a good gimmick you know a
road warrior thing work but Hawk moved
down here I introduced him to his wife
she was an aerobic instruction I said
I'm gonna introduce you to her then I'm
out yeah because she's a wild one okay
yeah and so no matter what happens
yeah we're cool because I got nothing to
do with what's going on you want to meet
her here she is Dale here's Hawk they
ended up getting married you know ah and
so he was always here and I missed
seeing him a lot you know because I hung
out with him a lot and he they moved
away
he died oh he passed away I didn't know
that he overdosed yeah oh and she's
still around the neighborhood somewhere
I haven't seen her forever and then
another one of the guys that I traveled
with for four years on the road Brutus
Beefcake yeah him and I had a fallen out
the barber huh was he a real bar
somebody said he went to he didn't
really go to Redken or something or was
it he wasn't a real Barber and we had a
little bit of a falling out and so we we
don't even talk anymore you know I mean
we don't there's no nothing to talk
about yeah
you think you'll ever patch that up
um it's got a lot to do with the ladies
married too you know oh it does yeah
nothing really to do with him yeah so um
what was the draw you know what was uh
yeah this is one thing the last thing I
was about what was the steroid use like
because I used steroids when I was in
high school you know we would get test
200 or 400 I don't know somebody made us
I think made us some 700 one time
um One Time We snuck it back from Mexico
like shampoo bottles and stuff so it had
like we'd have like soap like we'd it
would be like soap in it but we were
using it you know was it pretty heck was
it pretty just a normal thing that
people were using
yeah I mean you know it's like uh I
think it was 1990 it became illegal
it was legal before that oh yeah you'd
go to the doctor and get a prescription
for it oh wow you know that was another
thing the guys had a problem with they
would take so much of it they would ramp
their system I think they stressed their
system their hearts out I don't know if
anybody ever really died from just
steroids but if you had the steroids or
the Somas and the perks and the alcohol
and the coke okay
you're gonna create a fire you know yeah
so for me you know up until the 90s I
was always street legal I mean if I had
a bottle of deca or a bottle of test on
me it was a prescription from the doctor
and it was legal oh so the doctors used
to prescribe it oh God yes my levels
checked everything wow to make sure I
didn't right you were able to use it as
safely as possible yeah because when you
turn 30 that's the peak of your
biological clock and then from that
point on it's down oh you know so
I'm gonna hold you up I'm 43 man you're
on the way down man so there's a
bunch of good HRT doctors around hormone
replacement doctors that can hook you up
I know I've thought about that I don't
want to lose my hair though that's the
scary part you know you won't lose your
hair you don't think
maybe I'll start looking into that yeah
but anyway back long story short about
1990 and before then everybody I knew
because I knew a lot of baseball players
I knew a whole lot of football players I
knew a lot of hockey players all
professional guys they all use steroids
[Music]
there was only one guy I actually knew
that didn't use him that was Bob
Backlund you know Bob Backlund yeah he
was a champion before I came along and
okay red-haired I've heard of him yeah
so anyway
but everybody I knew dabbled in it and
even if they said they didn't they did
believe me and so at the end of the day
when it became illegal we kept joking up
you know because we were out cheering
biceps like this that wouldn't get fixed
and muscle tears everywhere your thumb
gets broken and the Philadelphia
Spectrum at one o'clock you go to
Russell Madison Square Garden that night
you don't want 10 weeks it's got to be
healed in six weeks yeah so we just
never really stopped and then
Vince McMahon was on his you know major
role with this company doing great in
the federal government targeted him you
know so we had to clean things up well
well yeah eventually they targeted him
and they drugged the poster boy in he
almost gonna go for events let's get
Hogan and so we had a a rough go of it
for a few years with the federal
government Vince wants trial and all the
stuff they said he did he didn't do you
know he didn't distribute it he didn't
sell it yeah you know I mean you just he
did it on your own
I'm not going to get it from my boss
yeah so that that's what they're trying
to paint him in the corner it wasn't
true
and they tried to get me to testify
otherwise wow you know which I said I
would and then when I got on the witness
day I told the truth and made a quick
exit and didn't go back to New York for
five years really oh yeah because that's
where the feds were because that's where
events they're trying to prosecute him
out of Brooklyn wow so when I went to
work for Ted Turner I couldn't even
wrestle anywhere in New York for five
years so they thought you were gonna rat
on him yeah and you just said he didn't
do it well I became a government witness
wow because to avoid prosecution you
know because they were they were going
to get somebody and they were going for
events and then if they weren't going
for events they pulled me aside and
actually told me what was going to
happen to me if I didn't say this I went
I didn't know that no problem no problem
brother you got it
so when I got on the uh Litton stand
there in Brooklyn
um I had a weird jet waiting to the
airport airport I had Alex isaacman one
of my attorneys that handled Larry Flynn
the Larry Flint trial and another
attorney Henry Holmes with me and when I
got off that witness stand I didn't even
go sit in the courtroom I went out the
side door yeah got in the car I went to
Tito airport and didn't come back for
five years
until the three three prosecutors uh
Charlie Rose or either Charlie Rose of
Sean would say one of them got busted
with a bunch of kilos of coke and then
the other one died of cancer I can't
remember who was who but the third guy
that had the FBI flag him and I became
good friends oh really yeah so once that
was over then I went back to New York
yeah you know but yeah it was it was a
it was a crazy run they were just trying
to Target Vincent
trying to you know do what the
government always does to people you
know oh yeah and he just basically
didn't do anything they said he did and
he was
not that guy yeah
did you ever get to meet Michael Jackson
yes yeah
I was asked to get off a Disney bus
because of him no way why because what
happened well they have these little
little buses they'll Park tourists
around on it uh at Disney yeah oh yeah
like little trolleys is what you look
like
and but not the carts that are hooked
together it actually looks like a little
mini bus a little red trolley okay and
so all of a sudden
um
I was sitting there with my family uh my
first wife and my two kids watching the
fireworks at Disney and all of a sudden
security guards come and go well you
need to scoot down you need to move the
far side of the cart and move the far
side of the cart and then Michael
Jackson came in
and uh he's by himself he's by himself
with a with a couple security guards and
he came over he goes I'm very sorry
about them making you move and I said
it's okay brother not a big deal man
it's all cool I guess you know it was
him oh yeah yeah and so I really didn't
talk to him other than that say it was
cool that's the only time I've met him
was when they made us move down and get
out of his way you know I don't think
they want us to look at looking at him
or anything but he came down and
apologize oh he did yeah did he look
like a little or did he seem like kind
of not I did what did he seem like I
don't know I was just sitting down he
just he looks like he does on TV to me
you know he had the black hat on
and uh wow he's all covered up and had
the glove this thing glued on because he
was like I mean it was that must have
been interesting for you to see yeah
right my daughter Brooke was flipping
yeah she was like seven or eight years
old I can't remember but yeah but that's
the only time I've ever met him he just
was real polite but the security guards
are Pricks yeah but I understand why
they had to do it I get it yeah yeah
he's probably paying him a lot yeah plus
say he didn't want his picture taken and
didn't want to be asked for autographs
so I get it yeah and what about Michael
Landon do you ever meet him no I didn't
why would you bring that up I love
Michael Landon so do I yeah really a
little joke oh dude he was my favorite
Highway to Heaven even that show Little
House on the Prairie I love Michael
Landon I was more of a bonanza guy I
respect that yeah you seem like a little
more Bonanza but
um yeah I love Michael Landon man that's
cool there was just something about I
just yeah I don't know he played like
that father like the hero you know he
was like
I mean you probably looked at him the
way we looked at you you know it was
like man that guy not really I was
looking more like a Haas oh yeah yeah
maybe not
but that's that's great but yeah Hulk
it's nice to meet you man and it's an
honor and thank you so much for just
being a great Entertainer all these
years man well I'm glad you're a fan I
had no idea oh yeah man I have no idea
we needed you dude we I don't
even know our TV we would
balance the on the back and we
would hold each other's eyes
open like don't you miss this
boy and we would miss it dude
sometimes but sometimes we wouldn't man
when Gene okerlin would be on there God
and we were ready boy we would
weird tuxedo we didn't have tuxedos but
we had like these like we would cut us
black sweatshirts with like the white
shirt on remember 10 like we were the
guys you know yeah he was my guy Gino
and I I brought him from Minnesota with
me yeah because I was in Minnesota and
met him there the Baja and then when I
went back to uh New York
when they wanted me to come back and do
this crazy International thing with
Vince Jr I brought Mean Gene with me
he's my guy yeah he seemed like a cool
guy to have around yeah and was he just
a little bitty guy yeah he was a little
bit when I moved to Minnesota I was
single
I had an apartment behind the med center
where the Mall of America's there was a
place called The Met Center there and
there were the visaya apartments behind
there and that's where all the Northwest
stewardess lives right oh yeah I mean
Gene came over one time and he was
married he wouldn't go home he stayed in
my apartment for like a year and a half
and said dude aren't you ever gonna go
home he wouldn't leave he just stayed
there and lived with me I said okay fine
whatever
you know he just wouldn't go home he's
just interviewing stewardesses hey
Claire you're headed to work today he
was brutal man that's fun did you see
Prince over there in town yes God yes
yeah I used to go down and play at a bar
called The Caboose
um there was another bar that they was
at the bar he played at all the time
yeah downtown Minnesota okay Minneapolis
and then I played at boys in the river
all the time there's a band called
fragile there Bonkers is a place where
you see uh are you familiar with
Minnesota yeah some we used to go was
that bar place we went to bonkers
Boyd's on the river I can't remember
Burnsville Bowl any of these places I
mean I'm talking in the 80s okay but
they had real pimps I'm at my first real
pimp in Minnesota yeah oh no doubt yeah
but right on Hennepin Avenue where Moby
Dicks was there was a bar called The
Caboose and I used to always go in there
you know after I wrestled or whatever
since I was single I didn't have
anything to do so I just go down there
and drink beer and play guitar all night
with all these bands
and you know I was fresh off planes so I
could still play yeah you know like my
fingers hadn't been broken and screwed
up and so many times so I could still
play pretty well
so I'd go down there and I always go
into Princess Club you know First Avenue
there and the first day I went in there
he walked on stage and started playing
wow you know the very first time I saw
it walked in the place and so you know
that got me coming back a lot yeah you
know and I only saw him two more times
there but uh he would come in there and
just play like for three hours because
it was his Club yeah and we just sit
there and listen to him and it was it
was amazing to watch him you know I met
him one time said hello to him it was
just a brief passing he goes yeah I'm a
wrestling fan so thank you man cool
yeah I just never sat and talked with
him or anything hmm pretty magnificent
though
just even see him you know yeah it was
cool man he was cool but you know I just
uh really dug his music man oh yeah man
yo yeah he could do it
you could do it man thank you for all
the music you put out in the world you
know it's all good Brothers we're not
done yet no no yeah yeah and you're not
I mean it didn't mean to make it seem
like that but thank you still here for a
reason I just haven't figured it out yet
well we're glad you are and uh thanks
for all you've done so far man oh thank
you very cool it's been awesome to
witness and to be a fan of thank you
brother very cool
feel I'm falling like these leaves I
must be
Cornerstone
oh but when I reach that ground I'll
share this piece of mind I found I can
feel
it in my bones
[Music]